le 12 décembre dernier vous faisiez vos
courses au Lidl de Chaumont et tout a
basculé lors de votre passage en caisse
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé alors je vais
aux courses comme comme d'habitude comme
on aime voilà je me trouvais donc à la
caisse j'attendais pas mes courses et
puis jeter un peu dans ma bulle et puis
je sens comme une agitation autour de
moi mais j'ai pas le temps de réaliser
que je me prends un coup derrière
mais sans rien dire en fait j'étais
tellement dans ma bulle que j'entendais
rien et donc au début je croyais que
c'était un coup de bouteille
donc j'étais sonné à terre et puis je
coprais que je comprenais pas ce qui
m'arrivait
et ensuite
[Musique]
ce qui s'est passé
ensuite l'homme je sais j'ai tout ce que
je me souviens c'est que j'ai revu
l'homme revenir donc me donner un
deuxième coup au dessus de la tempe avec
un choix
et donc
[Musique]
oui j'ai eu très peur je me suis dit que
j'allais mourir là
et donc je me lève parce que j'ai un
coup d'adrénaline je me dis il faut que
je bouge chez nous il va me tuer vous
êtes blessés
quand il était à terre parce que c'est
la première c'est la première personne
que j'ai vu se prendre les deux coups de
H c'est ça qui a fait que je suis
intervenu au moment où je suis voilà je
suis rentré dedans avec le chariot il a
eu le temps de se relever et puis de de
partir derrière avec la caissière qui
l'a emmené s'enfermer dans les toilettes
et pouvoir
alors donc là Sullivan tu tu sonnes
douleurs ou tu as tellement d'adrénaline
que tu non en fait sur le coup je sens
pas du tout de douleur je suis vraiment
dans l'adrénaline et j'ai pas mal du
tout mais enfin je sens le sang qui
coule sur moi donc je m'affirme aux
toilettes justement avec la caissière
qui m'a qui m'a retenu la porte
et une fois arrivé devant le miroir
c'est là que je vois mes cicatrices
et je vois tout le sang qui sort de ma
tête
excusez-moi vous inquiétez pas suivi
Manon on a le temps tout va bien
je demande de m'aider mais tu es
tellement donné que bon je veux pas
aujourd'hui parce que voilà j'étais pas
dit que terrible
mais voilà je veux vois ton miroir et
puis tout de suite là la pensée qui
vient c'est je ferme les yeux je vais
appeler mon père et puis je vais faire
mes adieu donc
j'ai pris mon téléphone
j'essaie d'appeler mes premiers je sais
que je perds tellement de sang que mon
téléphone il fait n'importe quoi
j'essaye de quand j'arrive pas j'essaie
de vous savez ok Google
j'essaye de
l'activer mais il reconnaît pas ma voix
j'avais ma voix comment dire ça
j'arrivais pas à bien parler en fait
j'étais tellement angoissé que ça va pas
sortir
mais mon père il comprend le plus
important et puis il prend la route
et juste après j'ai réussi à avoir mon
copain aussi
et puis là que je raccroche je me vois
encore une fois dans le miroir et puis
là je me dis faut que je fasse quelque
chose je peux pas je peux pas mourir là
dans les toilettes
donc j'avais mis une serviette
autour de moi donc je la prends je
commence à faire des points de pression
et je lui ai dit Maurice
tu es désolé
[Rires]
pour toi merci
est-ce que je peux poser une question
est-ce que tu as été pris en charge très
vite oui c'est très rapide tu as eu la
sensation que ça allait vite oui je suis
resté une 10 ou 15 minutes dans les
toilettes et puis c'est beaucoup plus
les pompiers étaient déjà là à ce
moment-là mais une fois que je suis
sorti j'étais pris en charge tout de
suite
alors Sullivan c'est que bon tu es très
ému on peut le comprendre
donc ça c'est vrai que quand tu nous
parles du téléphone fait d'abord on se
met tout à ta place on imagine tous la
scène et là donc impossible tu n'arrives
pas à non je suis à même que je me dis
je me suis dit j'ai crevé à cause d'un
téléphone qui veut pas que ma voix quoi
c'est c'est
idiot mais je me suis dit je vais mourir
à cause de ça quoi c'est pas possible et
c'est de parler à la saillant pas du
tout non bah non j'ai pas eu le temps
façon je crois que je pensais plus à ma
vie que qu'autre chose à ce moment-là
donc quand on décrié autour de toi tu
t'es dit je peux pas téléphoner tu
voulais te parler à ton père tu voulais
lui dire je voulais appeler quelqu'un
pour faire mes aides tout simplement et
puis
une fois que j'ai eu mon père au
téléphone mais complètement sorti de la
tête et la première chose que je lui ai
dit c'est il a une attaque à Lidl voilà
et encore je lui ai dit ne viens pas
au départ je lui dis ne viens pas si
j'avais peur qu'ils sont encore là mais
bon voilà il est venu quand même
donc là et c'était bien oui alors
une fois je me retrouve dans le camion
de de d'ambiance
et donc il faut des points de pression
comme j'avais fait avant et puis le vent
de bandage et tout ça pardon
je sais qu'à ce moment-là j'étais super
apaisé j'étais vraiment bien parce que
je sentais bien j'étais sur mon cœur en
sécurité dans le camion mais j'ai
toujours pas mal encore
et puis c'est vrai que j'ai vu la tête
de mon père se dépasser
mais oui mon père vous pouvez imaginer
aussi qu'il était super stressé hurler
après moi j'entendais du camion
était déposée par une amie donc elle
était aussi
alors
Tariq considéré qui vous a sauvé la vie
oui je pense que il a contribué à me
parce que s'il aurait pas réagi avec le
chariot je pense que ce sera jamais sur
moi vu que j'étais à terre
vous l'avez revu Tariq avant de voir ici
ou pas du tout oui en fait j'ai revu
entre temps j'ai revu à Hajar donc c'est
l'aide aux victimes
c'est vu quelques temps j'ai remercié à
ce moment-là encore une fois et voilà
on est venu ensemble alors
tu viens avec moi parce qu'il était
stressé allez au revoir
qu'est-ce que vous l'avez dit à Tarik
c'est quoi les mots que tu lui as dit
je sais plus vraiment je sais que
que je les remercier parce que probable
j'étais enfin il m'avait probablement
sauvé la vie
que je voulais tout prix le rencontrer
pour le remercier de vive voix parce que
au départ quand j'ai remercié j'étais
encore dans la chambre d'hôpital parce
que tu as passé une semaine à l'hôpital
une semaine c'est ça ouais donc voilà et
puis j'ai quand même eu un cerveau bien
sûr
[Musique]
presque totalement résorbé donc là j'ai
rendez-vous le 11 pour m'assurer que tu
ailles bien
on te sens Sullivan et c'est normal on
sent extrêmement quand même perturbé par
cette histoire et c'est normal on le
serait pas aujourd'hui est-ce que tu
arrives à reprendre une vie normale
j'essaye je suis je suis au mieux je
suis avec mon copain donc quand même au
départ il me disait à la maison il faut
que tu te reposes mais tu disais non
sorti t'es retourné au Lidl d'ailleurs
non jamais non je crois que j'y
retournerai pas honnêtement je crois que
j'arrive pas ouais tu passes devant
parfois tu habites à Gaudé ou tu oui bah
oui je vis à côté donc je passe souvent
devant et d'ailleurs quand je veux
lancer une maintenant honnêtement
j'arrive plus ah ouais non même pub ça
me rappelle des souvenirs directement
c'est fini tu t'es vu partir ce jour-là
mes dernières minutes dans les toilettes
justement et aujourd'hui quand tu tu
marches dans la rue quand tu vas dans un
magasin quand tu fais est-ce que tu fais
peut-être toujours une appréhension
est-ce que tu te sens un peu sur ma
garde par exemple en magasin
je peux pas enfin j'arrive plus à tout
seul une fois que tu vas accompagné
parce que sinon je stresse très très
vite et en caisse c'est pareil je
m'aimais plus de dos je reste sur le
côté parce que au moins là je verrai des
choses à arriver
et puis
non je pense que je pense que maintenant
j'ai trop peur de retourner dans un Lidl
c'est
un être humain
de ton agresseur non en fait j'étais
vraiment mon service donc non j'ai rien
vu j'ai même pas vu l'arme qui tenait
dans les mains
juste en dit que tu ailles pris un coup
puis un deuxième et en fait t'as rien vu
non tu as juste entendu des sons
qu'est-ce qui te traite de ça c'est des
sons c'est des cris c'est des alors oui
c'est c'est les sons et les cris j'en ai
pas entendu forcément donc j'étais
vraiment dans la bulle de ce moment-là
donc j'ai pas entendu mais par contre
par exemple je me souviens toujours de
toute ma vie c'est quand j'étais dans
les toilettes et que je me voyais perdre
mon sang donc la sensation de la du sang
qui coule sur moi
le bruit le bruit qui sort de Fall du
sang qui sort de ma tête
c'est vrai
l'enquête est-ce que est-ce que tu suis
un traitement pour essayer de reprendre
un petit peu pieds par rapport à tout ce
que tu peux avoir comme angoisse un
traitement non
traitement des conseils des psy des gens
qui t'aident parce que vivre avec cette
angoisse permanente c'est horrible oui
je veux dire si je vois j'ai pris Topsy
donc j'envoie un un certain jour et puis
l'autre je vois quelques jours après
comme ça moi j'aurais toujours
Jean-Paul le plus possible j'ai un
psychiatre aussi normalement j'ai
rendez-vous aussi bientôt pour
[Musique]
lui expliquer un petit peu ce qui s'est
passé
mais non je suis pas tout seul je suis
pas tout seul même si ça a pris un petit
peu de temps à s'enclencher je suis pas
tout seul au niveau psychologique j'ai
quand même mes parents et tout ça aussi
pour m'aider enfin ils sont pas dans ta
tête non ils sont pas dans ma tête c'est
sûr mais ça fait quand même du bien d'en
parler bien sûr
l'enquête elle en est où elle avance ok
pour l'instant je n'ai aucun aujourd'hui
il est en hôpital psychiatrique mais il
est interdé c'est la piste d'un acte de
folie c'est quelqu'un qui était soigné
avec beaucoup d'antécédents
psychiatriques qui apparemment
schizophrène et très probablement c'est
encore tôt pour le dire mais qui vu ces
antécédents ne sera jamais jugé parce
que sera déclaré je pense irresponsable
il est incarné et voilà quoi je dis ça à
plat comme préparer des haches et des
couteaux avant le magasin absolument
mais pour le moment sur l'enquête c'est
plutôt la piste d'un coup de folie qui
est retenu par par les enquêteurs alors
Sullivan est un petit message à passer
avant en fait il y a trois jours j'ai
perdu ma grand-mère
et je voulais lui rendre hommage
parce que c'est inquiétait aussi pour
moi par rapport à tout ce qui s'était
passé et donc j'ai perdu le 3 janvier et
donc je vais lui faire un gros bisou
là-haut et
je vais dire que je l'aime
je suis contente c'est beaucoup
inquiéter pour toi c'est bon oui
j'espère que tu vas pouvoir reprendre
une vie normale et j'espère aussi
tout ce que je veux
Tariq on espère pour toi que tu vas voir
les bonnes nouvelles et que tu vas
pouvoir être aidé que tu vas trouver du
taf assez vite parce que tu le mérites
et j'espère qu'on va t'aider parce que
tu as fait que un drame a été évité et
Sullivan s'il est là aujourd'hui c'est
certainement grâce à toi et je pense que
c'est aussi merci à vous deux d'avoir